hoy vamos a practicar cómo estimar la
resta de números con decimales nos piden
estimar el resultado de 12.93 menos 6.1
recordemos que este signo de igual
ondulado quiere decir aproximadamente
igual pausa en el vídeo y traten de
estimar el resultado de esta resta y no
necesitan una hoja de papel para hacer
sus cuentas el objetivo de estimar una
cantidad es encontrar mentalmente un
resultado aproximado a la respuesta
correcta rápidamente sin que tenga que
ser la respuesta exacta para resolver
esto a mí me gusta redondear las
cantidades a la unidad más cercana así
que el 12.93 lo redondeamos a 13 que es
la unidad más cercana y el 6.1 lo
redondeamos a 6 por lo que 13 menos 6
nos da 7 y este es una de las opciones
sin embargo cuando hacemos estimaciones
podemos tener resultados un poco
diferentes pero este ejercicio fue
diseñado para que sin importar el tipo
de aproximación que hagamos obtengamos
un resultado parecido al de la opción
correcta a veces ustedes pueden resolver
estás
mentalmente por ejemplo 12.93 6 es igual
a 6 y 93 centésimas menos 10 centésimas
es 83 centésimas seis unidades más 83
centésimas es 6.83 de esta manera pueden
calcular el resultado exacto el cual es
aproximadamente igual a 7 el objetivo de
este ejercicio es familiarizarnos con la
estimación de cantidades pues en muchas
ocasiones no necesitaremos de una
respuesta exacta sino de un resultado
aproximado para darnos una idea de lo
que estamos hablando hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí nos piden estimar 56.75
menos 46.9 aproximadamente a que será
igual causa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo
vamos a hacer lo mismo vamos a redondear
cada número a la unidad más cercana aquí
yo lo voy a escribir pero ustedes pueden
hacerlo mentalmente 56.75 lo redondeamos
a 57 y 46.9 lo redondeamos a 47
la resta es bastante directa y es
aproximadamente igual a 10 es la opción
a aunque en la vida real no tenemos este
tipo de opciones múltiples normalmente
vemos las opciones en algún examen o
tarea porque así es más fácil de
calificar las estimaciones pueden variar
por lo que elegir la opción más cercana
es más sencillo
hagamos un ejemplo más de nuevo pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo nos
piden el resultado aproximado de 49.7
menos 4.16 el 49.7 lo redondeamos a 50 y
el 4.16 lo redondeamos a 450 menos 4 nos
da 46 y la última opción coincide con
esto espero que se sientan más
familiarizados con esta forma de estimar
cantidades no estamos haciendo nada
sofisticado simplemente redondeamos cada
cantidad y hacemos la resta para darnos
una idea de cuál es el resultado
aproximado con esto terminamos